the establishment would have you believe
that the Trump White House is in chaos
it's lacking the skill and vision to
lead us during wartime what is the
strategy in Syria right now there really
is no strategy I don't see what that
strategic vision is the Trump
administration has no coherent strategy
as everyone else has noted there is
still no strategy on Syria wrong wrong
of course Trump has a strategy he just
hasn't told it to himself yet so it
doesn't leak
people don't understand Trump is a
tactical genius we've seen it all week
Trump's mobilized forces to defend
America from the greatest threat it has
ever faced a book now I've always been
anti book with three exceptions Atlas
Shrugged the Bible and Tucker Carlson's
bestseller I'm not racist but that book
ends exactly how you think it to us
tomorrow a higher loyalty leaks into our
nation six remaining bookstores
it's a slanderous account by James Comey
who treasonous Lee wrote down the things
the president said and did this is war
and we are prepared five days before the
book launched the commander-in-chief
steam unleashed a high-tech preemptive
strike the RNC has set up a war room to
go after Comey in response to the book
they've got a new website out lion Co
me.com yes lion Comey calm I assume
because this dude calm get a load of
this piece of dotnet and Christ dot
org we're all taken this is an
administration that takes national
security threats seriously when the RNC
heard this book was coming out
they put Syria to the side mission
accomplished they set up a war room
formed a Rapid Response Team to shoot
down incoming book excerpts arm their
soldiers with talking points and set
them out to the front lines to pummel
the enemy Jim you're the ultimate liar
Comey is
without integrity commies only hire
loyalty is to himself James Comey is a
liar and CNN are a bunch of perverts yes
I've said CNN are perverts for years
wolf Blitzer's gimp suit has a zipper
for the beard and while the assault was
underway Trump himself despite painful
bone spurs personally joined the battle
deploying a heavy barrage of
ground-to-air tomahawk tweets James
Comey is a proven leaker and liar at one
of the worst botched jobs of history
he's a weak and untruthful slimeball he
is not smart the worst FBI director in
history it was my great honour to fire
James Comey yes now that's how Twitter
was meant to be used suck at American
Choppers meme oh thanks to this
sustained assault the only assault Trump
has ever committed hashtag the enemy was
neutralized James Comey 'he's much-hyped
interview last night was a bigger
letdown than my nephew's middle school
play which became 11 Angry Men at the
last minute because someone got stage
fright and puked I see all over the
dressing room you're an embarrassment to
the family Nathan trumpet his allies
brought the Thunder all week all Comey
brought was a pocket full of old news
and a satchel full of maybes was
president Trump obstructing justice
possibly do you think the Russians have
something on Donald Trump I think it's
possible I don't know was it a mistake
yeah I don't know but maybe I don't know
whether the current president nighted
states with with prostitutes peeing on
each other in Moscow in 2013 it's
possible but I don't know good god the
stuff James Comey doesn't know could
fill a book
that is desperately trying to sell the
only crime that was revealed during this
interview was the 60 minutes that ABC
stole from my life except for one
critical piece of information is Donald
Trump unfit to be President I don't
think he's medically unfit to be
President I think he's morally unfit to
be President he strikes me as a person
of above-average intelligence who's
tracking conversations and knows what's
going on a person who sees moral
equivalence in Strongsville who talks
about and treats women like they're
pieces of meat who lies constantly that
person who's not fit to be President of
the United States on moral grounds you
heard him opposers play it again he
strikes me as a person of above-average
intelligence yes yes surrender accept it
there's literally nothing else you could
take away from that clip as a great man
once said mission accomplished
[Music]